thank you
no I'm not going to be banned rather
rather what do you think I'm gonna get
banned bro
I told you I'm gonna be cheating for the
next 30 days or however long the sub is
reporter does nothing absolutely nothing
valve has finally opened up the CS2 beta
to a lot more people which is awesome
but instead of giving access to someone
like myself who's been playing the
series since they were [__] cognizant
they are giving access to people who are
literally live streaming themselves
cheating
[Music]
late last week valve released an update
to The Limited Test that along with a
new Inferno and a host of other changes
provided access to a boatload of new
players since then we have got to hear
and see a lot more opinions about the
current state of play performance how
the game feels and so on but admits the
discourse of what people like and
dislike about CS2 is a growing concern
about an issue that we would have hoped
to have left behind in CS go
hackers now a bit ago we did a video
covering an interview that Sparkles did
with Infamous hackers who were already
testing out cheating software in cracked
versions of the CS2 Limited Test and
although they were mostly restricted to
cheating against bots offline it's hard
to understate just how quickly things
like this can get out of hand it even
works with like Health ESP and stuff you
know and that's pretty simple you know
we made it like about one week now our
last Bastion against these sickos was
supposed to be the new and improved vac
because even if cheaters got into our
matches they would be swiftly banned
saving us time and our sanity however
with CS2 opening up to a ton more people
cheaters have proven that there are a
lot of cracks in the system most notably
this guy who was live streaming himself
cheating on YouTube just the other day
he just wants to be first pisses me off
running away from it what is the smoke
gonna do
yes a user by the name bad guy Nessie
streamed himself blatantly cheating
using walls scripts Aimbot and even
showed what the interface looked like
but here's the kicker this wasn't just a
one-time thing Nessie has been streaming
himself cheating for over two months now
and according to Reddit users who were
going through his content the guy
constantly bragged about how he couldn't
get banned and even if he did he could
just buy more accounts from Shady
Russian websites now luckily after a
quick look over his social media it
seems that his most recent account has
been backbanned and he's yet to go live
since but I also noticed a few other
interesting things for starters since
YouTube doesn't take a strong stance
against it there's a ton of cheaters
live streaming on YouTube personally
whenever I open Tick Tock live I'm just
bombarded with people showing off their
cheats in any given game I think it's
bizarre but I never paid it any mind
since I mean the absoliving hellscape to
begin with but a quick search into
YouTube and you are bound to find plenty
of people doing the exact same thing
especially in CS2 now the other thing I
noticed from looking at nessie's Twitter
and all his other cheater friends is
just how Brazen these cheat sellers are
not only do these sellers often operate
like Brands but they straight up
showcase their hacks on Twitter for all
to see and even tease valve like they
have nothing to be afraid of just look
at the damn Twitter account for aimware
who claimed to have been raising
standards since 2014. they have a logo a
banner a forum they even have a [__]
ticketing website if you have issues
with their service it's a full-on
business operating in broad daylight now
I often see a lot of people frustrated
that Services can operate out in the
open on Twitter and YouTube like this
and honestly I get it it's everywhere
but at the same time it's not really
that surprising anymore and even if they
didn't have social media accounts like
this finding cheats is only a quick
Google search away and has been for a
very long time my real concern is
whether or not valve is equipped to deal
with this new generation of cheaters the
new vac does look super promising and
the fact that a match will end if a
cheater is found is a great addition but
since vac currently doesn't have kernel
access to our computers these people can
just keep getting more accounts and the
cycle never ends now to be fair
improvements likely will and can be made
for years to come so maybe this is all
just a case of managing our expectations
it's possible that one day encountering
hackers is so few and far between that
we can just live with it the question is
do you have an acceptable level of
cheaters you're willing to face I
honestly have no idea what my limit is
either but hey to be fair nothing can be
as bad as the way CS go is right now
which is the game I'm currently stuck
playing so hey I guess that's something
to look forward to
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring the notification Bell for Unique
bite size videos you won't find anywhere
else hit us up on our Twitter Instagram
Facebook and tick tock